all right let's get started for today um
your homework two was due last night but
you still have late days so you can keep
working on it just a little bit longer
um then let's see your homework three
will go out later today late tonight
probably which will be due in two weeks
from yesterday after which you only have
one homework left so pretty far along in
the class um it is also time to start
thinking about your final projects
so um start thinking about what you want
to do look at the guidelines on the web
page essentially want you to do some
interesting research ideally the
beginning of a research project some
initial Signs of Life of something new
or maybe already far along with
something kind of tied into that um
related to the class you'll have a
deadline soon to submit a proposal
through Google Docs we'll comment on
that we'll go back and forth with with
you and at some point say that your
proposal is approved at which point you
can get going you'll have a milestone a
month or so from now and the final
delivery which will be a a write up and
a recorded presentation at the end of
the
semester um and yeah take advantage of
office hours to come brainstorm ideas
for your projects if you're not sure
what to do it's often hard for us to
just propose something but once you come
with even a rough idea of your own it's
easy for us to kind of brainstorm
together with you around those ideas any
questions on Logistics
okay well today we're going to look at
diffusion models this was not part of
the class four years ago it didn't exist
uh four years ago uh the the paper uh
Jonathan H wrote uh was written I guess
less than four years
ago um it's pretty exciting because in
some sense almost everything that
happened the last four years at least in
the image space seems to have been
involving diffusion models uh either
just diffusion models or other things
combined with diffusion
models so um here's one of the things
that I uh really enjoyed when open eyes
Dolly 2 came out which is now a couple
years ago it was possible to start
giving prompts and it would then
generate art for you so for example here
a masterful oil painting a Persian
exotic cat discovering there is standing
crypto losses while checking their phone
okay that's the prompt you feed it into
the uh Neal Network the diffusion model
and out comes beautiful artistic
rendering of the prompt and by the way
the little color scheme at the bottom
right that's a signature that it's a a
dolly generated
image now if you're active in AI at all
then probably recently heard about this
thing called sora which just came out
last week it's a diffusion model not all
the details are available but it's a
diffusion model that is capable of um
generating full videos from descriptions
so in this case beautiful snowy Tokyo
ums I wanted to play out instead of go
to the next slide let's see if that can
work beautiful snowy Tokyo city is
bustling the camera moves through the
bustling City street following several
people enjoying the beautiful snowy
weather and shopping at nearby stalls
gorgeous Sakura petals are flying
through the wind along with snowlakes
so I watched this
video it's very hard to spot anything
that's off about it now maybe if you
look at the very detailed aspects of it
you'll find some things that are off but
from a quick class this looks like just
a drone video shot behind a couple
walking in Tokyo but actually it's just
made up by AI That's How good these
models have become uh Philip told me
this was one of his favorites um
Reflections in the window of a train
traveling through the Tokyo
suburbs that's what you ask for and then
here's what you get
um
it's rendering Reflections on the window
and when it goes dark you see more
detail of the person that's standing in
front of the window it's pretty amazing
it captures all those aspects of what
video or real world perception would be
like um here's another one a cat waking
up its sleeping owner demanding
breakfast the owner tries to ignore the
cat but the cat tries new tactics and
finally the owner pulls out a secret
stash of treats from under the pillow to
hold the cat off a little long longer
okay let's see what happens here by the
way this is one that they published as
one where not everything looks as
perfect to give people a sense of what
might still not be fully working uh so
keep a close eye on what's actually
happening it's like there's a third arm
emerging under the sheets but I mean
other than that it's it's pretty amazing
uh that one moment was of course a
little bit off but that's also you know
they sh sharing it they could have
Cherry Picked and left this one out but
they're actually sharing it to show
where the opportunities for improvement
still
are and then uh another one that they
shared to show opportunities for
improvements again long caption in this
case five gray wolf pops is it really
five looks like three but now it's four
now it's five um now I
mean now in the real world that's hard
to pull off but in a movie you can
imagine that this could happen where
there's like these puppies are just
sprouting out of nowhere and uh doing
something um so obviously there are some
limitations to to the realism to be fair
a lot of videos online are made in a way
that there are limitations to the
realism of these videos they could not
happen in the real world so um I think
unless you truly filter videos for
realism you might always end up with
something like this if you're not if
you're not careful but um again it's one
that they shared to show there is still
room for improvement it's not game over
just yet um you can do this with robots
too so here the previous ones were from
open ey Sora system uh and that project
was led by um Bill peeves and Tim Brooks
who just graduated with their PHD from
Berkeley uh less than a year ago uh
we're already working on diffusion
models for video generation at Berkeley
but of course didn't have the amount of
compute amount of data annotated data
available to do this kind of you know
Leap Forward that is possible with the
resources open I offer them now here's
uh one done by another Berkeley student
Sherry Yang and um what you'll see here
I mean if you follow the discussion on
Sora online you'll see like oh does it
really learn about physics it's like not
realistic realistic and so forth here
it's specifically Trend to include a lot
of Robotics data and so it's interesting
now if you include a lot of Robotics
data manipulation data what might happen
and do you start getting some realism
that maybe it could help robots think
through the consequences of their
actions and so this is a sequence of
videos so it starts with a frame then
make the request put can on top then a
new request can be made close bottom
drawer and so forth so it's a sequence
of commands made as this is this video
uh gets generated in in little chunks um
but what you see is actually it follows
the rules I me it opens the drawer it
pulls it out it doesn't just open it in
an unexpected way um and so when it
moves an object the robot actually has
to go there grasp the object to then put
it where it wants to put it um so when
you watch all of this sure some little
details aren't exactly Picture Perfect
it's not trained with a you know super
large model the way the Sora was trained
so there's more artifacts but the gist
of this model knowing how to do a task
like grabbing an object opening a drawer
closing a drawer putting something in a
drawer it's actually captured in this
model so it's pretty interesting
interesting that this is actually uh a
real possibility
now okay so today's lecture will consist
of uh two components first I'll go over
some of the basics the history of
diffusion models um which I think Often
by seeing the history of how things came
together it can give you an
understanding of maybe where things are
headed more so than just seeing a
snapshot of what is the latest and
greatest uh model um it can also teach
you something about how maybe a new area
could emerge and what what the steps
could be um from there Wilson and Kevin
will dive a lot deeper on some of the
aspects of the latest and greatest
models and what matters to make them
work and as you know you'll get a
homework on diffusion models uh released
two weeks uh from today to to dive even
deeper
yourself okay so um seate of Affairs of
this class I right now as well as the
field of generative models in 2020 for
visual generation there were
autoaggressive models flow models Len
variable models Gans Gans give the most
realistic images but they have lots of
bells and whistles and they struggle
with truly covering what's in the data
distribution often you get high quality
when you look at individual image bases
when you look at the Corpus of things
generated it feels too narrow in what
it's uh covering income the motivation
to work on something new at the time for
Jonathan ho P Berkeley at the time
namely uh diffusion
models
so obviously there was work before this
and I'll highlight some of the work that
was before this work um that motivate
motivated us to go in this direction
once I explained what we did here um but
I'll explain this paper in a bit of
detail to give you a foundation for
everything that's coming in this class
and then uh we'll work from
there
so this is uh what some sense the first
generation of the noising diffusion
fistic models could do um these were
state-of-art results at the time um as
good as Gans were capable of going doing
I mean maybe gas could do slightly
higher resolution still at the time but
it was clear that this was getting
towards the same level of quality that
Gans were getting at that time and Gans
had had 10 years of development and this
had essentially you know very little
development tiny amount of development
in
comparison um
and by the way not just the quality uh
is what we looked at to evaluate this
but also if you look at the details of
the diversity of things generated it was
much better diversity than Gans could do
so it had it was going towards same
level of quality while having much
better diversity better coverage of
what's in the data in some sense so it
was clear that there's a high potential
there what's the model uh that was
proposed in this paper um turns out the
fusion models there's many ways to think
of them many valid interpretation ations
um that's part of what complicates it
because some people might ince a new
architecture but use one way of
interpreting diffusion models with one
type of notation not a paper use a
different ination different notation and
then to use another architecture and
actually you could use both improvements
together but it's just you know there's
so many ways to think about them in some
way I think the simplest way to think of
them or one of the simplest ways to
think of them is that they are just
denoisers so the way you train these
models is you have an image
x0 you add in this case gausian noise to
it at the pixel level step by step and
you try to learn a model that goes in
the opposite direction removes the
noise the reason you that might be an
interesting thing to do is because if
you can do this really well then you can
start with just a Pure Noise image and
it somehow turn it into a realistic
image if it's doing a good job or if you
had maybe a low quality image you could
turn into a high quality image because
it could denoise that low quality
image if you look look at this model um
in some sense this thing here is very
similar to what we call Z in the ve in
Gan is just a very special kind of
latent space the latent space here is
this like same size as the original
image in this case again these things
will change as we look at more advanced
diffusion models but same size as the
original
image and it's just pure gaussian noise
and we can actually guarantee that if we
do enough steps of adding gussan noise
that we will turn the distribution of Z
into a gaussian distribution you add
enough gaussian noise and the way it's
done adding the gaussian noise which is
the the Q steps here going right to left
is you effectively
shrink the image you scale it down let's
say multiply by 0.9 all the pixel values
shrink them towards zero and then add
gaussian noise you also Center the image
around zero so you have a values from
negative 1 to plus one let's say for
your pixel values and then your orig
orinal keep shrinking away while you
keep adding gaan noise that's how you go
from right to left so the right to left
path is highly trivial nothing to be
learned you could think it as good thing
bad thing but nothing to be learned just
noise noise noise and on the end you get
a gussan uh distribution to go the other
way is harder and has to be learned so
we have to learn a model that can
recover XT minus one given XT and
assuming the steps are small you can
actually assume that the correct way to
go back is to actually also model it as
a gaussian in the opposite direction um
where you now have to learn to predict
the mean and the variance of that
gussan so the steps are small enough
this is not uh this is not a real
approximation is is
correct of course you need to learn the
MU Theta and the Sigma Theta to make
sure it matches up with uh what's in
your
data so this view on things is
conceptually relatively straightforward
um but and then in principle you could
just train a model that has a you could
even maybe use a sigma as a hyper
parameter and just train a model for me
thetas that predict a slightly denoised
version from your uh previous
um noisy image the way it's actually set
up is a little different in some sense
it's simplified um training time you
sample an
image then you sample a Time step you
sample gaussian noise and then you
create a image with noise added to it x
z is your original image you're scaling
it down and then you're adding gausian
noise here this Alpha
T the larger it is the closer to one the
more noisier result will be and
essentially there's a scheme here where
depending on the time that you sample
you end up with a very noisy image if
your time is high which is your very far
in the diffusion process or if your time
is very small then there's just a little
bit of noise added to the
image and what you're supposed to do
then is to take in this noisy image this
thing here is just your noisy image as
well as the time step of diffusion so
you're essentially told there was this
much diffusion happening to achieve this
image this noisy image now learn a
neural network Epsilon Theta that
recovers the noise that was
applied
that's conceptually equivalent to
recovering the original image because
once you recover the noise that was
applied you can subtract it out from the
noisy image and get the original image
and so you can actually also formulate
it in a way where you say I want to
recover the original image but this is
the formulation used here we're going to
recover um the noise that was
applied and we'll soon get into some
specifics about why one might be better
than the other later in lecture when we
dive deeper um but for now let's assume
we just try to train Network that
recovers the noise that was applied from
looking at the noisy image um it turns
out if you look at the details of the
derivation and so forth that this
Epsilon Theta is a scaled version of the
grad log P Theta x what is this P Theta
X is a distribution we're learning we
don't have direct access to it really
all we have is this sampler that turns
noise into um images but under the hood
there is a corresponding distribution P
Theta X it's set up that way um and
we never directly evaluated but it turns
out that this Epsilon
Theta is essentially trying to recover
this what is that quantity it's saying
move my X into the direction that under
my model makes X more likely so let's
say it's just a simple simple gusan
right and your x axis and your X is
sitting here and you say oh well move X
bit this way because it's higher over
here now this is in high dimensional
image space obviously it's a more
complicated picture to draw but the
notion is that locally you say how can I
make my image more likely under my model
and that's what's um done by Epsilon
Theta once it's trained
well and so if we then look at the
sampling um multiple time steps so in
principle you could do it with with one
time step um
you take your current
XT and you calculate the direction in
which to step to den noise it a little
bit and then you you essentially make
that correction and that's what you have
here and if it's not your final step yet
you also add some gausian noise to it
that's to stay within distribution of
how things were trainers in The Next
Step you have a within distribution
noisy image for which you can again
apply the the uh Epsilon Theta
calculation to step in the right
direction and repeat so if you look at
this interpretation here it's really
saying every step along the way when I'm
sampling I'm trying to nudge my current
image to be a more likely image under my
learn distribution and add some noise to
stay on course for the process with it
with which I have been training so that
the next step also succeeds this process
here is actually called um the whole
process called
l
sampling and it's actually a way to
correctly sample from this distribution
P Theta of X so it's a it's a
justifiably correct way to do
this so some sense that's all there is
to it I mean there's a lot more to it
obviously because there's many more
years of work and many breakthroughs
that have happened since this paper but
in some sense it's all there is to it
you learn to identify the noise that was
applied and then later you use the
Ability you learn that to take na image
in a better and better uh situation one
way to think of this is that imagine
your images live on some kind of
manifold and uh your noise is here which
is of the manifold it doesn't look
realistic at all what you really trying
to do is Bump this thing step by step
back onto the manifold of realistic
images that's what's happening under the
hood or at least one interpretation of
what's
Happening
now if you check the paper there's a
long derivation there not going to step
through it um but essentially you can
start from
this um model that we drew on top say
that what we're doing is we're entally
maximiz maximizing the log likelihood
under that
model of our data and then we use the
variational lower bound introduce that
variational distribution Q which happens
to be fixed in this case but the same
one we used for Vees you can multiply
divide by it swap the the order of the
log and the expectation and it becomes a
bound and then you get um the objective
that's being optimized then if you
reshuffle it a bit to reduce the
variance you get this thing over here
which in turn leads to the algorithm I
showed
you don't worry about it too much um but
you can go read there's a bunch of
papers that get into a lot of details
about how to exactly tie it to um
likelihood
objectives here I'm going to give you a
bit of detail the reason I'm giving this
is to give you a sense of what in this
2020 paper was already there as a
starting point to understand how things
have changed since
then the backbone was same as pixel CNN
Plus+ which we covered uh last week um
so a unit based on a wide res net okay
so there's a
confet um that um is architecture has a
wide res net and there's a unit
architecture which means essentially in
a unit you go from
highr U shape is
this L low not sample but learned I
guess reduce resolution go into feature
space and come back out on the other
side with hopefully a better version of
the image it could be a segmentation map
of the image it could be a d noised
image that's how units are set up and
the way the reason you're drawn this way
is because typically you don't just try
to go from here to here but you also get
the information across so essentially
get the deeper semantic understanding
coming from the bottom and then the
details that were maybe lost coming from
the side to help you reconstruct what
you need at your current level in the
Reconstruction of the image on the
right um some normalization scheme uh
that was considered weight normalization
uh replaced with group
normalization um 33x 32 models as you go
through the unit there were four step
steps so one 2 three four actually got
it right um for the 256x 256 there were
six such steps of going to lower
resolution and coming back
out all models have two convolutional
residual blocks per resolution level and
self attention blocks at the 16x16
resolution so at the bottom here well at
the 16 X6 doesn't have to be the bottom
I think it would be here it would be an
attention block so Transformer
effectively living there to help I guess
do some more complicated
processing diffusion time T which is
conditioned on as you train right how
much do I need to uh Denise this thing
uh cidal position embedding en coding
just like is often used with
Transformers the cfr1 model 35.7 million
parameters then 114 million for Elson
and SL ahq and then
256 um for the largest model train
you'll see that some of the later models
are only like single digigit billion so
this paper was already kind of not
exactly singled digit billion model but
pretty close to it
um what comes out is in this case guess
great diversity of faces this is trained
on a a phase data set is based on
celebrities so it's kind of matching the
diversity of whatever celebrities tend
to look like um obviously if you follow
the news Google have made some all kind
of modification on their image
generation to to skew it in various ways
that are not the data per se um this was
just straight up trained no no
manipulation just whatever is in the
data uh you know learn learn to generate
things similar to the
data bedrooms churches all generated
really well uh diversity reflecting the
diversity in the data um we look at the
scores remember Inception score and FID
um Inception score was how clearly do
things belong to a class because that's
a good sign of having a Crea a very
clear image um ours this is the doo
infusion paralytic models 9.46 actually
second highest among the unconditional
models only the most advanced Gan was
better at the time and then FID which
also measures the diversity how well you
cover the things in the data um much
better than anything else that was
trained unconditionally so great sign of
the potential of these models to cover a
distribution that has a wider
spread
you can interplate with these the way
you do it is you take two images you
apply noise to it like certain number of
time steps of noise and at that point
you then literally average the two noise
images and den noise them back out um
depending on how far you are in you'll
get different things so for example
these are
the these and these are the source in
images then next to the reconstructions
the reconstructions give you a sense of
I go fully into noise and come back how
good is my diffusion model at recovering
the original it's actually pretty good
um it's Al give you an upper bound how
good the interpolations are could
possibly be because other information is
lost about the original image um but
then when you look at um the
um the interpolations you see that
indeed it looks a lot still like this
person starts edging over to the woman
on the left and here's something in
between and here it's starting to look a
lot and a lot more like the woman on the
left so there a gradual transition um
from one to the other it says 500 time
steps I think we had trained with a th
time steps which means that you only
halfway bring it to um the full noise
image rather than all the way um the
reason for that we do a comparison here
if you have two images that you're
comparing or interpolating this man on
the left and this woman on the right if
you do zero steps of diffusion you're
just averaging so you can see what's
happening here it's just pixel averaging
not much is happening except for an
image that kind of doesn't fully Mak
sense if you do a whole lot of steps you
go all the way to your gaussian
distribution
um
well you can actually look right here at
500 we still get the original
reconstructed but beyond 500 we start
losing even the original we make the
image so noisy that we diffuse back out
we don't get the original back and so
the information was lost about who was
there and so this is kind of the the
natural way to choose that cut off is to
say hey I need to still be able to
recover my original otherwise I'm not
going to get interpolation and so beyond
here it's just not going to work very
well and actually if you go all the way
you see oh we had a great diversity and
some sense of U faces generated but it's
nothing to do with interpolating at that
point because it's just pure noise that
that we're recovering from nothing to do
with the original
images okay um you can actually go look
at the paper for more details but
there's a way you can think of diffusion
models as effectively being a
generalization of autoaggressive models
how so autog of models imagine autog of
model as you have your image you removed
the bottom right pixel then you move the
pixel next to that you're move the next
one think of instead of adding gausian
noise you're just blanking out one pixel
at a time so the entire imag is blanked
out it's not exactly the same as adding
gaussian noise obviously there's a
difference but you could think of that
as a possible process and then the
reverse process would be what an
autoaggressive model is doing it's
filling it back in one pixel at a
time so diffusion model is in some sense
doing this in a generalized coordinate
space and it's also doing in a
randomized way it's randomly iner
directions erasing information by adding
noise and gradually over time getting to
a completely erased image and then
learns to go back uh to the original
image the fusion model of course has to
be as deep as the number of pixels for
that analogy to truly hold through but I
think in the more abstract level um it
it holds through no matter what now you
might wonder why did Jonathan uh ho at
the time come to me and say I want to
work on diffusion models um it didn't
come out of nowhere so he had been he of
course knew that Gans were quite uh
constrain in terms of the ability to be
uh cover cover multimodal distributions
struggling with that um and so he had
seen these two papers especially um this
one here by soul dickstein and
collaborators from 2015 5 years before
that moment so been sitting there
largely ignored by most people um
sitting there for five years at that
time actually introduced diffusion
models from a thermodynamics
perspective and has essentially the same
ideas I mean didn't get all the details
right to get the same level of um of
generations happening but at a high
level had the essential
ideas then in parallel Jonathan had seen
that
um yang song and Stephan IR um at
Stanford had gotten some really good
image Generation by um
essentially running longer V Dynamics
sampling on grad log PX and by directly
learning a model that can predict the
grad log PX which is what you need for
the Lun Advan sampler and so
Jonathan realized that the well thought
that there could be a very strong
connection between these two works and
while this one in Jonathan's perspective
introduced it in some s in a more I
guess clean way to work from this one
here on the right was getting already
quite strong results in terms of it Mis
generating ation and then he
investigated how to to bring them both
together and that led to the to the
paper we
wrote okay so from here a quick a quick
run through of um what happened from
there then opening I wrote a paper um
diffusion models beat Gans on image
synthesis uh the title says what they
were trying to get across
um it was beating them now not just on
divers which the original paper already
did but also on individual image quality
when they would ask people can you rate
which qualities you like better um it's
better um selected samples from their
best image net 512x 512 model um this is
the you know really good image
generation that is uh emerging here um
some things they looked at they would
learn the variance in Jonathan's paper
it was a hyperparameter that was tuned
in their paper the variance of the um
process was learned um and they also you
looked at the demonistic sampler which
we'll talk about more later which is
both variants are are still in
consideration today they made some
architecture improvements increasing the
depth versus the width um increase the
number of attention heads use attention
not just at the 16x 16 but also at 32x32
and 8 by8 the end of this lecture day
you'll hear of miles that only use
attention and no convolutions anymore
the TR the trans is going that way here
already um bigan residual block for
upsampling and down sampling activations
um rescaling residual connections with a
factor 1 over < tk2 so little things
that can help um they introduce
something called classifier guidance so
they said because we want have images
that look realistic and we measure that
by looking at the classifier score if
something is belong to a certain class
or not why not provide some guidance and
um train a classifier that classifies
onto the classification level because
these unised learning data sets are
often actually labeled uh we just use
them as UNS supervised but why not use
also the label uh for once and note that
this classifier has to be train on noisy
images because you need to learn to
classify the noised images just as well
as real
images and then guided you take the
gradient with respect to XT that makes
the image not just more
likely as an image right before we were
saying oh we're here we need to Denise
get back into the manifold now it's
saying oh actually you know there's this
many manifolds in some sense and
actually this is the class label we want
so we need to somehow drift over here
and so we get an extra term for that to
make it Max belong to that class so we
have in some sense every step of the
sampling is what we had which is a noisy
image then awaited contribution of the
this is the grad log PX term and then a
weighted version of the grad log py
given X yes question it looks like from
one of the prev slide that like when you
inject noise there is a threshold where
you cannot like the noise anymore so is
that clear when there is this thres and
how can you on image if you have
destroyed the whole information yeah so
you might end up wasting some time or
you might tune that a little bit um
yeah and so these are the um comparisons
they did Big Gan deep the biggest big
Gan model on the left
um this diffusion model in the middle
and then training set on the right the
thing to pay attention to for example if
we look at especially add this set over
here is that big Gan generates these
flamingos all in pretty much the same
configuration it's a bunch of flamingos
together seen from far away whereas the
data set has them in all kinds of
configurations so clearly big collapsed
onto a specific mode for the generation
whereas the diffusion model doesn't have
that
issue okay
now this classifier guidance helps
generate more realistic images
um but now we need to train this
additional classifier which might cause
some challenges um it's not what people
do anymore um then actually Jonathan hoe
and collaborator Tim Solomons introduced
a way to get guidance without training
an extra classifier called classifier
free diffusion guidance um if ever you
only see this it'll look a lot like hey
some kind of classifier idea classifier
ideas used to guide but the name name
comes from the notion that it's trying
to contrast it with the classifier
guidance classifier guidance explicit
use a classifier here we will start with
classifier guidance which is push it
towards making the specific class label
you want more likely but then we'll
apply Bas
rule when we apply Bas rule we get um
the classifier goes out of it we get the
distribution in the opposite direction
now the opposite direction distribution
x given y That's our generator we're
already working on that we're already
training that so that's great our py
that becomes a zero because the grad
with respect to X of py doesn't do
anything there's no X in there and then
we have a marginal PX so what we see is
by applying base rule we can turn this
into distributions that we already have
because this is a conditional generator
and a unconditional generator so as long
as we imp parallel train both a
conditional and unconditional generator
we can achieve the same thing as
classifier guidance but without having
to train a classifier hence the name
classifier free guidance um but in terms
of no mentally what the signal is it's
still like a classifier it's still
guiding in some sense towards a specific
label it's just doing it not relying on
an explicit classification model but on
a combination of conditional and
unconditional
model so you get a nudge no these are
the epsilons in our notation earlier
nudge in the right direction for X
condition on Y and for just X in the
unconditional
distribution what does it look like if
you're sampling um you go through
multiple time steps of going from noise
to image um you um then generate the
direction which you're supposed to step
this
here is saying you know more generate
something more like my class conditional
sample which I'm trying to generate um
but then subtract out this because
remember on this Slide the unconditional
is subtracted out it's pulling you away
from being a generic sample and pulling
it towards a specific class of sample so
it's subtracted out here um so that's
the negative sign here and then if we're
generating a conditional sample the one
here is the term we already have we're
already trying to generate a conditional
sample and then there's the weighted
correction to that which is the
difference between Epsilon Theta with c
and without
C okay um we update our sample um then
add noise to it and
repeat um the training uh during
training you essentially just train a
single M because you don't want to be
training two neural networks um just
sometimes you erase the label from
what's being fed into your model or
another way to think of is you introduce
a n+1 label that you feed in when you
want to be uh unconditional and then um
that's how you train it some of the runs
I mean some of the updates aren
conditional some of them are
unconditional otherwise everything is
the
same pictorially um as you go to um more
and more guidance you get sharper and
sharper concentration around the things
that are extremely representative of the
specific class um you can also see this
here um in some sense you also get what
Gans tend to have you get a
concentration on the most some iconic
examples of the class and you get less
diversity so there's a trade-off here
it's a tweaking parameter how much
classifier free Guidance Do You Really
Want the more you put in the more
realism but also the less diversity in
the results that you are are obtaining
so this here is non-guided you get a lot
of diversity but things don't look as
like oh wow this looks like a you know
super clear uh real dog and then the
more guided you go um the more it looks
like a real dog but it's pretty much
always the same dog in pretty much the
same
pose here's another example um left is
non-guided the Corgi is in all kinds of
situations um and then right is guided
and it's all these close-ups um depends
what you want also sometimes maybe you
want the result on the right maybe
sometimes you want the result on the
left um that might depend on your use
case
this is pictorially the thing I just
talked about remember Inception score
effectively measures how realistic
something is and as there is um some
more and more training and more and more
guidance happening it just keeps getting
better and better and better more
realistic um but then the FID which also
measures diversity and where you want to
score low uh starts getting worse as you
have more and more of
this so very simple way to achieve this
classifier guidance is doing classifier
free guidance because you only need uh
to still generate a generator you don't
need any discriminators just a
conditional and unconditional generator
which you can do in the same
model okay what does Glide do glide then
said okay this is great these diffusion
models kind of work why don't we just
condition them on text instead of uh
class labels 3.5 billion parameters now
um for the higher resolution model an
additional super resolution uh diffusion
model so it's in two stages first you
learn to go from text to image 64x 64
then you learn to go from 64x 64 to 256
by 256 um the this diffusion Guidance
with caption conditioning now rather
than class conditioning um tried clip
guided diffusion what would that mean
clip guided diffusion it's where you say
oh I want my thing to look more like
something that clip Associates with the
class that I want the same kind of a
gradiant idea um didn't work as well as
uh the I guess more straightforward
thing this was the first time that it
was possible to uh just kind of generate
images of a pretty wide range of things
that looked uh quite good um so exciting
to see this this was becoming possible
um you can imp paint with it um by
erasing some things and then um you know
give a caption because you can then put
noise on the thing and then I'll d it
satisfying your caption while hope
hopefully retaining the rest of the
image or you could freeze the rest of
the image so you can't really uh change
it um more examples of that you can
incrementally build scenes this way by
marking things off as needing to be
noised and then Den noised with a way to
satisfy your
caption so this is the guidance here
right the classifier free Guidance the
difference between the conditional on
the caption and unconditional generator
nudge and then clip guidance would be to
look at whether clip is Happy um with
the with the classification label or not
but it happens to not work as
well um more samples to show how well
this
works um from there there was actually a
sequence of models that uh came out
partially and parallel do one came out
in parallel to Glide and then Deli 2 and
three came after that um
let's let's take a look at those so
Dolly one um why am I covering it here
because Dolly 2 and Dolly 3 are
diffusion models but doly one is not a
diffusion model but I just want to
mention that it exists yeah I
questionus
laize because we know we want good
images we want the diversity like
increase the distance eventually want
that they do not look exactly the same
orc the
same yeah it's a good question can can
we do more and you know can we avoid
that concentration on specific you know
images for specific class and maybe the
way I would think of is that the way
it's been worked around is by doing
caption conditioning rather than class
conditioning because once you have the
richness of captions you kind of can
describe in a lot more detail what you
want and hence now you could argue for
the same caption I still want a lot of
diversity you might want to think about
that um but at least for a um you know
you have the control to change the image
the way you want and you can create the
diversity hopefully that you want as you
do
this so Dalia do one was actually just
the autoaggressive model you tokenize
the image you tokenize the text and you
just Auto aggressively go from text to
image um just a few additional well
8,000 additional tokens for each image
uh possible tokens for each um image
that's the space uh we covered the vqv
couple lectures ago it was a variant of
that uses a Gumble soft Max rather than
a straight through gr estimator which
allows it to fully train against the VA
objective which wasn't exactly true for
the vqv so it's a bit cleaner in some
sense but it's the same um idea um and
then 250 million text image Pairs and
then they did some reranking here at the
end so a group of urals in is near the
trees and here it is images generated
the top row is best of 512 based on clip
score the bottom row is just the best of
one so did you get lucky or not and so
what you see here is um and they studied
is the quality of images wasn't
perceived as high as the Glide model
quality of images but the diversity
achieved was higher in in this model
um transation ability to compos many
Concepts and that was one of the
exciting things that emerged out of this
that people hadn't really seen before
you could say for example um let's see
illustration of a baby hedgehog in a
Christmas sweater walking a dog which
probably didn't exist but it can somehow
recombine these ideas into an image
that's being generated and was uh very
exciting to see that possible for the
first
time Dolly 2
made essentially um image generation
come of age um the cat example I gave at
the beginning was a dolly 2 example um
it came of age I would say in terms of
quality and the things it could do it
didn't really come of age in terms of
Simplicity um the doly 2 model is pretty
complex compared to today's models um
but it was the first one to have that
really exceptional ability to create
high quality images from text very high
quality images what did they do they
said okay effectively I'm having a Glide
model here so a text conditioned
diffusion model
decoder but I'm not going to just text
condition the text yes comes in from
here it does make it in but I'm also
going to actually turn my text into an
embedding and I'm going to translate
that embedding into a image embedding
and I'm also going to condition on this
image embedding and this text embedding
came from clip which is unsupervised
image text alignment Training Method
that generates both text and image
embeddings and so they would train
something that learns to translate
between the text embedding and the image
embedding you might say why are they're
not the same if there're supposed to be
a line that turns out images are much
richer than text in detail so the image
embedding tends to have more information
than the text embedding and this
translation here that's learned is
another diffusion model the one that
worked best is another diffusion model
because they're really good at modeling
multimodel distributions so you go from
this text edting to a good one of the
many possible good matching image
embeddings and then from there do
another diffusion run to get your image
out and then you might do another run to
up sample another one to up sample again
this case no conditioning in the up
Samplers why well you can maybe use more
training data if you don't need captions
to train your up Samplers you can use
any image anywhere to train your
upsampler let's see Wilson I need to
hand it over to you soon because you
have a lot to cover let me see um here
are some of the examples from
um from Dolly 2 um they also they
actually called it uncp also themselves
because it's really you know taking a
clip embedding and turning it back into
an
image um you can encode with clip then
decode and Sample and what you see here
is that indeed uh once you encode it
with clip um the clip encoding is
something higher level semantic because
once you decode you get semantically
related Concepts back but not the same
thing back so this some kind of evidence
for the semantic level understanding of
clip and also the ability to deal with
that multimodal generation you need to
solve uh given uh it's a semantic
understanding not a pixel level
understanding you get in your
embeddings interpolations in clip
embedding space allows to interpolate uh
things that are wildly different yet uh
make good
interpolations um and then Dolly 3 came
out just recently um which was
essentially um saying maybe we just
needed more detailed captions for our
images we need a larger data set with
more detailed captions our captioning AI
systems are maybe good enough to
generate detailed captions so let's
first set up a really good captioning
system run that on a lotted images use
the detailed captions to train our
system to do generation and that's um
they don't give a whole lot of detail in
the paper as part of it um it sounds
like they're running some kind of stable
diffusion model which uh Wilson will
cover um but they didn't really share um
a lot of detail that did seem to
indicate that with their stable
diffusion um the decoder is still a
diffusion not a VA decoder um but again
um not a lot of detail being
shared um and this is what you can get
now I mean the realism is becoming quite
extreme at least I mean it's terms of
what you would want in these situations
you can provide very detailed captions
pays attention to all the details in the
captions in to the DI line of work there
was a simpler line of work at Google um
Jonathan ho was one of the main
contributors there again and essentially
they said um we just need to scale up
this text to image um models the right
way um so they just take a text encoder
generate a text text embedding from
using a language model rather than clip
or anything like that just use a
language Model turn text into a text
embedding text conditional diffusion
model super resolution super resolution
and call it done and the results are
extremely similar in quality and
abilities as the open ey Dolly 2 model
so um in some sense this is the the
easier um well the simpler architecture
uh compared to Dolly 2 but um
uh yeah these things were just developed
in in
parallel one of their key observations
was that as they decided to use bigger
models that they realized that
the main main benefit from scaling up
was in the better text Tings at the time
rather than better or larger diffusion
models so people had not been using good
enough text Em betters uh to get the
best quality results
um and they introduced an efficient unet
uh which means you put more model
parameters at the low resolution where
things are more semantically processed
uh compared to previous
models and here are the imagin results
again very similar to dolly2 uh type
results also works with text pretty well
um Dolly 2 didn't work as well with text
but Dolly 3 uh works better with text
also Wilson I'm going to give it to you
here use your finger to swipe and then
you can just write
yeah okay it's better than last time uh
okay yeah so as Peter mentioned I'll
mainly be going into some of the deep
deeper stuff for like some portion of it
and then Kevin will be uh talking about
the rest of it um so we'll start off
with like some of the more fundamental
stuff for diffusion models about like
sampling noise schedules and um how
things are parameterized and I'll talk
about specific like neural net
architectures that people use before and
like
now okay okay so there's so I guess one
unique thing about diffusion models is
that um during training almost everyone
most people train the same way using the
same objective that that Peter talked
about um but then the main difference is
during inference when you actually want
to sample an or video or or whatever
data you're actually modeling uh there's
like a lot of choices there's been like
so many papers on on different kinds of
Samplers um but for now I'll probably
just we'll just cover the single one
called ddim or DM uh mainly since it's
probably one of the simplest to
implement and also easiest to understand
on in terms of the the samping
algorithms um so just to start off I'll
probably do some slight notation
changing uh just to make things a little
bit simpler um
so on the top right here so here this is
just the standard D noising that we had
in the ddpm um and then we'll just
replace in variables so uh Alpha T and
sigma T are like this and then the G
noising step is is just XT is equal
Alpha t xot plus Sigma T
Epsilon and then for the D sampler so
the the way the the reverse process
works is that it's like essentially like
XT minus one oops
you get like some function of
like uh let's say XT and then you apply
that like two times until you get to T
is equal to zero uh and then you have
your image or video or whatever um and
the way this update here works is
actually decently
intuitive uh so here is just up here on
the top right is just the reordering of
the original equation that I had because
originally it was like XT is equal to
Alpha t
plus Sigma T Epsilon just shuffling some
terms around to isolate X notot um and
that's exactly what this is here so this
is your your diffusion model outputs the
Epsilon here and then um you can apply
this equation up here to estimate so
this is basically X hat so this is
saying I'm given uh my noisy image at
diffusion time step t i compute Epsilon
and then I can kind of run it through
like the reverse format for the for Den
noising to estimate what the original X
hat not
is um and the way update is formulated
is basically some waiting of this x hat
knot so Alpha T minus one and then this
is like kind of like the direction that
your model predicts to update so plus
Sigma T minus
one and then this will just be equal to
XT minus
one and then you kind of apply this
update mult multiple times until you get
to T is equal to zero uh one other way
to think about DM is you can kind of
think about uh think about this as kind
of like a like differential equation and
then DM is using like the most simple
like like Oiler based solver uh to to do
the reverse
process and then the one nice thing
about DM is that you can then choose
different sampling steps so for example
most diffusion models you train for like
1,000 denoising time steps or 4,000 even
I se 8,000 um so if you want to like the
standard way to sample would be you do
like 8,000 like reverse steps for the
diffusion um but for most other Samplers
you can just flexibly choose you can
kind of like um like skip steps so you
you can do like like 20 or 30 steps at a
time so in total if like your diffusion
was a th steps and you do like every 20
steps then you'd have only like uh like
50 actual sampling steps uh the only so
the trade-off is that the fewer the
number of steps the faster it is because
the less four passes you have to make
through your model um but the the like
the the consequence is that your sampler
your your samples might be worse uh if
you have fewer samples or if you have
fewer steps um so this is just like a
there's not really an intuitive
understanding of like how many sampling
steps you want to do in the sense that
you probably just want to try everything
initially from like 10 to however the
max number of steps and then see uh what
the quality is like almost always
something like like 50 would probably
work so this is like different
essentially the sample quality the
different number of time steps so you
can see at time step t or or at 10
sampling steps the car is a little bit
blurry here but then it gets like
clearer and clearer as you have more
sampling steps but after enough steps
it's like it's usually like good enough
essentially
um and in this case usually 50 is a
pretty good number to just start with if
you just want to play around with a
model or something
okay um so that's a sampling algorithm
that one I also I wanted to mainly touch
on because DM is also very important for
other stuff that I'll be covering uh
which is used for to edit images and
videos and stuff like that um but the
next part is something slightly
different it's kind of touching on the
actual objective for for the diffusion
model so the standard ddpm is basically
like the L simple loss is a loss on
Epsilon
um so this is exactly just the the loss
that Peter showed Epsilon minus Epsilon
hat of that's
XT and there's a different and
alternative way you can do is that
instead of an L2 loss on Epsilon what
some people have also tried is you can
just do an L2 L2 loss on uh the original
image cell so instead of so instead of
the unet predicting the Epsilon that was
used to noise the image it's now
predicting the original image from the
the noise image so this is still
XT and there is like a relationship
between these two between Epsilon and X
so if this is your original denoising
equation you can do another thing to
isolate X knot very similar to what was
done for DM um and then you can take
this and then you can just essentially
plug it into there so here for these
ones it's
Epsilon here and this is Epsilon hat
that's the only really really the only
difference everything else is the same
uh and then if you kind of Shuffle some
terms around things cancel like like
this this cancels and then you can
factor out the the sigma T and Alpha T
um you get this
here which and then if you want to move
it to the other side the bottom is is
just doing the the reciprocal um so if
you do want to train with losses on x
bace
that's essentially equivalent to
training losses in epsilon space uh just
with a slight reting based on the time
step T Alpha T over Sigma t s and
another term for this here is is kind of
like the signal to no
ratio because here Alpha is you're
waiting on X knot and sigma is on
Epsilon so um so at like T is equal to Z
you have like Alpha t equal to 1 and
sigma T is equal to Z so your your s r
is is infinity because there's no noise
and then at T is equal to like the max T
it's the other way
around so your SNR would be zero in that
case um so that's like another like if
you read a diffusion literature it'll be
very common where they they refer to
this waiting as like the SNR or if I
take the log of it it'll be the log Sr
um stuff like
that
okay and so there yeah there's Epsilon
space and X space and there's one other
one that is is kind of weird do you have
a question no okay
um that but I it would be good to cover
because it's probably one of the most
popularizations that are used in like
almost every model right now um so the
way this new reparation works is that
here we have our
original weights before we replace
things so we have root Alpha bar T and
root one minus Alpha bar T and then so
this is constrained to be like this
follows the property that like Sigma
oops Alpha T Sig t s is equal to one or
you can also just view these as 2D
coordinates that that are just L on the
unit circle or part of the unit circle I
guess
um and um and yeah so instead of
basically basically doing it in terms of
time step T you can kind of do this in
like almost like polar coordinates where
you you reprize everything in terms of
f instead of T so this will just be the
angle of of this Vector here
essentially and uh and yeah so now the
for process is just is just this cosine
this just used to be XT is equal to uh
Alpha t
and and this is just cosine of pi and
this is just s of
f
um and then after that what they did was
they just took the
derivative to define a velocity as just
this term this is just like a standard
derivative of of the equation above uh
with with trig
functions um and then if you do some
math essentially the the DM update rule
can actually be I think the main goal
they did this is this is a really kind
of weird thing to do it's not super
intuitive at first U but the the end
consequence is that uh it really does
simplify the update rule quite a bit so
this is the DM update rule versus before
it was like uh something a lot more
complicated like XT minus one is equal
to like Alpha T minus
one XT
minus
Alpha
T something like that uh a little bit
messy but yeah um so now it's just a
function of basically the the Delta here
so cosine of Delta uh z f t here is just
x f t and then um plus the the V that
you predict so so in this case your
model is parameterized they not predict
Epsilon it's not it's not it's designed
to predict this this V like velocity
term that it outputs
yeah 5 T minus or instead of like minus
one it it just like Delta is the
difference instead of like a difference
of one I
guess that's how I describe
it yeah so the I mean in terms of
training in terms of implementation it's
it's quite like the math behind it is
quite complicated but in terms of
implementation it's like pretty easy
it's like almost no different than your
other uh the code for the other
objectives this is still XT um this
neonet it doesn't change the only
difference is that the Target that you
compute is different which is just
follows this formula uh so you still
take your you still compute Alpha T
Sigma T um and you still sample noise U
but instead of having the target be
Epsilon or X notot you just have uh V
which is this this this function of both
of
those and yeah so similar to how Epsilon
is related to or Epsilon space is
related to X space um loss in this V
Space is also related to
um xpace as well you you can follow a
very similar pattern of of
doing X not um or
sorry yeah of where you write things in
terms of X notot and then you can
replace things uh terms cancel again
like this in this term and then you
basically get this and then if you take
the reciprocal here you can also get
this which is basically just
like 1 over Sigma t^2 and then using the
fact that
they sum up to one if it's
squared let's do Sigma
t^2
so that's just equal to 1
plus which is just this this coefficient
here which is essentially different
waiting of of the original loss I guess
in this one it makes sure
that uh the loss is always at least like
a waiting of one regardless of what like
the signal ratio is versus for Epsilon
space it would be kind of like a waiting
of the SR exactly would range from like
zero to Infinity pretty
much uh yeah so in practice vspace is
probably the one that works best out of
all the ones I've seen it's it's kind of
subtle it's not like a substantial
substantial difference but this was from
uh I think video diffusion models paper
uh where so this is the the the top row
is the input frames and then the middle
is with Epsilon prediction samples of
that and then the bottom row is with v
prediction it's like you have to kind of
really look at it but there's like a
fewer
artifacts I think like maybe between
these two images is probably most
apparent I don't know if you know if you
can see on the
slides are you guys able to see a
difference it's it's pretty subtle it it
it's like a slightly grainier like for
Epsilon um but I think since like for
everyone it's just like a a why not I
guess so
almost all papers almost all papers I'll
be talking about like 90% of them will
end up just doing prediction in the
space um
yeah
okay okay and the last part okay so this
part that I'll move on to is is kind of
a subtle one but this actually
surprisingly makes a really big
difference and it's something that most
people would want to use or Implement um
if they're training a diffusion model um
so one of the main issues in these
common noise schedules for diffusion
models is that the relevant one is
original
here so original is the general like
noise schedules that people use so the
x-axis here is Alpha bar or or Alpha t
as I was describing so this ranges from
it should be from range go from go like
go go like monotonically from 1 to zero
and then you'll notice something weird
because it should kind of end at zero on
the last time step is at the last time
step of the diffusion process your
signal should be completely noise like
there should be nothing left in the
original signal but in this case these
noise
schedules this blue curve and something
like kind of above zero in practice it's
something pretty small so it could be
something like a like
0.06 or for a different schedule it
could be like like oneus 5 or something
something pretty close to zero
um but this is actually like a pretty
big problem that people kind of found
like like like if you train it with the
schedules as people have did for a while
you you'll still get good samp you'll
still get samples um but there's still
like a decent amount of improvement you
can get by fixing this weird issue and
the reason it's an
issue
uh is there a slide that was oh okay
never mind
okay I I'll talk about the next slide um
so I guess one of the reasons why it
doesn't actually end in zero with the
noise schedule is partially because at
the maximum time step of the diffusion
the at least with Epsilon base loss you
have this technically it should be Alpha
T is equal Z and sigma T is equal to one
so your your data should be completely
noised out and and filled with and
replaced with goua noise that's random
um but your objective your objective
becomes
something not very meaningful because
here you just have this this is just
Epsilon so then your your network is
saying I want to predict Epsilon given
Epsilon which is a very easy task to
learn I mean as long as your model
learns to be an identity function it
will essentially always get it right and
it probably will if you if you train on
it um so it's it's not a very meaningful
task
here and but the reason why we kind of
want to fix this that's kind of why they
needed like like this to not be zero
this to be something like like 1 eus 5
and this to be like 1 minus one eus or
or or something very close to to one
just so there's a little bit of signal
there to still do noise but the main
issue is that this is fine during
training but during inference we're
actually always starting from gou noise
we're sampling from from a a random
normal distribution and then we want to
denoise back
um but this is kind of out of
distribution from training so what what
it essentially ends up doing is the
network tries to kind of infer
like like you're sampling random Gan
noise but the during inference it it
always thinks that there is still a
little bit of signal in here um even
though it might be like a very low
waiting it it still tries to interpret
some sort of like Global signal where
there is none and then which kind of
messes up the like the sampling process
to an
extent and so basically what this paper
did was um they just enforced it so so
orange is is their model so they just
kind of shifted the schedule to actually
be zero here so that's actually zero and
then the other issue as I kind of
mentioned is that you can't release
Epsilon loss at this point just because
the objective is kind of meaningless so
what they did here uh was they just use
vspace loss so for
vspace if you plug everything in at T is
equal to the maximum t uh you'll just
get this objective which is Meaningful
so it's basically saying given random
noise just predict
uh the original
image here you mean
that okay yeah oh wait uh wait actually
sorry let me oh no no sorry this should
beon
um let me me a
sec
oops okay there's Epsilon
[Music]
minus
I will have to double check that uh I
guess the objective should be to predict
X knot but yeah
I'll you said this is minus
xot which is kind of weird I will double
check that later but yeah um yeah so the
the general process for for this paper
is uh it's pretty simple so you just do
the rescaling thing so like the the
orange curve that I showed before of the
noise schedule to actually end at Zer
SNR and then you can just take your
diffusion model if you trained it with
Epsilon you could just fine-tune it for
for like vspace prediction it's not that
big of a deal to change theorization
um and then you can just find tun on
vspace and also the the noise
schedule and they did this for some
models so for stable stable diffusion
was trained in epsilon space so so they
had to f- tune both for Zer ASMR and for
V or well I'm actually not sure what
iteration of stable diff they use
because one of the versions was Epson
space and then they find two into V
Space one so it's not sure um but this
is basically the the result is that um
in some sense it almost looks like the
the the variant like the diversity has
reduced a little bit or maybe it's also
more faithful to the The Prompt now um
but in general the the structure and
coherence like the global coherence of
the images are
are definitely sharper compared to
staple diffusion by
itself where you have like two beaks
here it's unclear what the thing behind
that is stuff like
that and I think more importantly it's
even more important video where I've
seen you can see a lot larger
differences so this was from uh emu
video from
meta uh so the the top one here is using
Zer SNR and the bottom bottom is without
so there are like differences in the
frames like for for these Dolphins here
it's a little bit less coherent where
they start kind of Shifting uh it's even
more obvious here where it's unclear
what what exactly is happening uh where
where the video kind of goes
crazy yeah versus the top row here it's
pretty smooth pretty coherent stuff like
that give that
time
okay uh so that was some Basics with
some of the diffusion uh details now
I'll start talking about the different
architectures and kind of I guess not
even just architectures but just like uh
philosophies of Designing these uh these
image or video generation
models so Peter I think briefly talked
about this with the unet so most most
diffusion models for for image or video
right now use UN based architectures um
with some small like modifications of
like uh like maybe in these lower layers
you have some self- attention um and
then you also include like a
conditioning of like the diffusion time
step embeding but aside from that it's
all pretty similar and then there's a
lot to play with in terms of like uh how
many filters you want per layer how much
you down sample how fast how how
aggressively you down sample different
resolutions uh stuff like
that and the exact way conditioning
works here is that you just have your
time step T So this could just be like
an integer basically and then uh you
feed it through a sinusal bedding very
similar to the positional beddings or
almost exactly the same as the ones in
like Transformer sinusal positional
Bings to get a a
vector and then you just feed it through
a small
MLP to to get a conditioning Vector
here and then you feed it into the
unit and once you get get into the
unit I've seen two generally two
different ways to do it the simplest way
is that uh so H here is like your
convolutional feature Network or or
features so it's like height by width by
Dimension and then your embedding is
just a single Vector you can
um basically single vector and then the
easiest way to do it is you just add it
so the this would happen at every single
like res Block in the network so if if
your network has 20 res blocks you you
you'll see this operation 20
times um something that is also used I
think more
frequently is that you you use the
conditioning as like parameters to
modulate your
features so you have a group nor on your
H and then you do a scale and a shift by
a function of of the of the time step
Ving
here so this this would be like like a
this would be like a single linear
layer so this is like a linear
projection and then this is also a
linear
projection and then you have new
parameters a
later okay so and kind of like some some
work after this the the question arises
because the the past models like for
ddpm was originally on on pixels uh then
the natural question you know with all
the work we've seen with VQ Gan stuff
like that is like can we make this more
efficient me pixels doing stuff directly
on pixels is usually kind of
expensive and what we can do here
instead of learning a VQ Gan is we can
learn a
vae exactly the same as like what we
covered two weeks
ago and the only caveat is the the loss
is all the same but it's I guess in some
sense it's like a beta ve where the K
loss is just extremely low it's like one
6 where it's
basically almost like incon like it it
matters a tiny tiny bit where it says
basically it's saying just like you can
you can have Z structured however you
want but don't make it too crazy
essentially like um to make
it roughly maybe it roughly keeps things
possibly bounded may maybe not have like
super weird like sharp discontinuities
or or behaviors um that's the
idea and but otherwise it's like very
similar to like architecture wise it'd
be very similar to like a VQ um where
you have your encoder and then Z and
then your decoder uh but the only
difference is that Z in this case is is
continuous
and that's also kind of important and
it's also one I guess one of the more
useful aspects of diffusion models
compared to like an aut aggressive model
these models can both like learn very
complex distributions um but the main
benefit of a diffusion model is that
you you don't need the data to be
discreet so like if I wanted to like uh
model like like the robot the movement
of a robot arm that's parameterized by
some sort of like like continuous like
joint Joint Forces or velocity or
something like that that's all kind of
like continuous data um if I wanted to
model with an autoagressive model I
would have to figure out how to like
make it discreete somehow uh which
depending on your modality can be kind
of hard uh or like non obvious how
exactly to Do It um so the nice thing
about diffusion is that it doesn't
really matter in that case where you can
actually just directly model that data
um which I think why it could be more
use where it has seen more dotion in in
other domains where it's not as obvious
of how to actually make something
discrete and this so this is the L the
fusion model architecture it is so this
here is your
Vee
and then this is essentially just ddpm I
guess or like maybe uh the one from open
AI like the the ADM model I remember
that's it's called U but just some sort
of any generic diffusion model it
doesn't really matter what it is um the
these two models are pretty are pretty
distinct so one doesn't depend on the
other uh just the fact that now after
you learn your V you have a much a much
lower dimensional l in space and then
you can model things a lot more uh like
a lot more cheaply where before it was
maybe 256 x 256 now it's 32x 32 uh and
it's a lot more flop
sufficient so same thing with the VQ Gan
there is still kind of like the speed
quality tradeoff where my Vee can like I
can super aggressively down sample
things I can down sample it to a single
Vector uh just in that case your your
reconstruction starts your
reconstruction at like your
reconstruction Fidelity starts going
down um but if your thing is super
compressed then you can also have a
really like it's really cheap for the
diffusion model to model it on the other
hand if your vae doesn't really compress
that much maybe only down samples for a
factor of two or or maybe do is even
down sample um then the consequence your
diffusion model would have a harder it
would be a more complex distribution of
model it would also be more flops
intensive uh stuff like that so it's
kind of like a sweet spot essentially I
think in ldm it was something like ldm
48 so what this training curve is is
essentially uh o over the course of
training for each model they just uh
took samples that every every so often
to measure the FID in this case the
lower the FID the better um so the so
you want the curves to basically be as
low as possible so like so these these
curves here which generally corresponds
to like the I guess the the middle three
here where for ldm 1 and two because I
think these experiments were also flops
constrained so all the models had the
same number of like total training flops
uh so I so I would assume they made the
models for ld1 and two smaller just just
because they're they're operating on
like more pixels so they're more
computationally expensive so they
couldn't scale as as big uh versus the
more compressed ones you can then model
um you can have a larger model because
it's cheaper it's like it's like a fewer
number of flops per parameter that you
add um and then you can make it even
bigger model for like ldm 32 where they
down sample I guess by a factor of 32 so
that's probably down to like 8 by8 uh
Laten size um but your your your
generation quality here kind you can see
kind of plateaus here um probably
because it could be bounded by like just
the like the Reconstruction quality of
the of the original image
itself
and then on the right here we have
sampling
throughput
um I think yeah basically where each
point for each color is like the model
at different number of sampling steps so
on the very right here it would be like
very few sampling steps because you have
higher throughput and on the very left
you would have uh much more sampling
steps because because then then it takes
longer to generate each image um but
these are some more results for for for
here where like red and purple generally
did did pretty well or green red and
purple so around a down something factor
of like 4 to 16 but this is something
you generally just like play around with
um it's a trade-off of like how much
compute do I have and how good results
do I want to get stuff like
that uh yeah and okay stable diffusion
uh I'm sure many of you have heard it or
even tried to use this model um is
essentially
ldm um pretty much exactly the ldm paper
I just talked about but scaled up on
more images doing text image generation
uh you have a VA that down samples by
factor 8 um it can support you can down
sample 2 56 down to 32 by 32 or even or
more generally uh I think natively
supports 512 down samples 64 64 uh it's
still the unit architecture with self
intention layers and then they Implement
uh text conditioning by just adding
extra cross attention layers after each
self attention layers and those cross
attention layers just uh attend from the
the image features to the the text
features and for this model the text
features we're just using a clip text
encode and yeah you can get some pretty
nice images this
was two two years ago down it came out
not not too long ago but yeah it's only
it's only gotten better ever
since and this one was more
recent this was I guess for from the
same the same company they released
stable video diffusion or uh yeah stable
video diffusion and uh the way this one
was
trained was fairly simple at at its core
it's almost the same model as just
stable diffusion they just initialize it
from it the main issue is stable
diffusion operates on images so it's
like 2D convolutions uh spatial
attention stuff like that so then the
question is how do you extend this to to
to video um and by video itself is just
a stack it's just the stacking of frames
over time um so what most papers did
like SB did here did and like a few
other papers um essentially what we can
do is you can just insert temporal
layers in in between so after after
every uh 2D com you have like a 1D comve
over time after every spatial attention
you have another maybe attention over
over time or maybe even just like a full
attention over the entire
video um and then and and then yeah you
you just do that so the temporal layers
are initialized from scratch and the
spatial layers like the 2dcs are all
initialized from like the original text
image model and you just take this model
and you just find tune it on your video
data which is probably one of the core
things that SVD looked at which is kind
of unique because their entire textto
video data set was basically completely
synthetically generated at least the
text part they just scraped a bunch of
uh videos online uh without text labels
and then they just used different
captioners uh to to label each video and
then use that as data after like a lot
of a lot of data
filtering like clip score basically how
how accurately does this text this
generate text correspond to the video um
so you want to keep ones that are higher
Optical Flo flow score usually helps to
filter out all of the videos that don't
have motion you know maybe this a video
there's a lot of videos of people doing
PowerPoint presentations online you know
so the image or or even videos of like
people just doing like uh yeah like
doing slides between like still images
you want to exclude all those because
you want to generate an interesting
video so you want video that has actual
motion um aesthetic scores I guess if it
if it looks nice it's kind of subjective
and hard to measure but people I guess
have collect their data sets to try to
measure or to try to collect data sets
with images with high that basically
look good um and OCR might be if they
may or may not want to include text um
in in their pip or like text generation
of like or like like image generation
with text in their
pipeline yeah um I guess one one other
point that would be useful to mention is
that uh like this General train training
Paradigm is not new as I mentioned to
SVD um the only difference with some
prior Works um like emu video from uh
Facebook or lumier from Google they all
also initialized from a text to image
model um but in those cases they
actually trained it a little bit
differently where they added the
temporal layers um but they trained the
whole model with the spatial parameters
Frozen so they only train the temporal
layers for those um yes I have two
questions you saying they just pre-train
the spatial stuff by itself to basically
each individual frame as if it's like an
image model and then after they
pre-train that they froze it and then
they train the temporal aspect so they
don't joint that's for those other
papers yeah they they don't or they they
don't they just take like because it's
probably let's say at meta there's a
whole team that's working on designing a
really good text image model uh that
they've collect a lot of good data and
they've made this really good model so
now the video team they're going to take
that and then they're just going to add
some layers freeze everything except the
new layers and and then train on video
and then my second question is do you
know how
theal attention
compar is this like really old way of
vieing like data but nobody really uses
it so curious uh 1C is use I guess it's
useful for local temporal dependencies
usually it's just both it's just both of
them they have both convolutions and
attention
[Music]
yeah um these are videos I guess oh I
guess videos won't won't play will they
not in the PD okay I guess you can
imagine it
moving for these it's not too different
from it's just like yeah move a little
bit the scene stays the same it's not
yeah a lot
happening
um okay uh okay yeah so so that was the
General Paradigm of where people have
trained these models of oh here is let's
learn a vae with a Laten space and then
let's just train a single model over
over this distribution so it's kind of
like a it's like a one-step generation
kind of thing um the other area that
people have explored is just using
cascaded models
okay um so basically where you
progressively generate so this is where
Peter was mentioning for Imagine they
have like a base model and then
different super resolution models that
generate larger larger resolution you
can kind of interpret it as a latent
variable model where the the lower
resolution images are different lat in
variables
um so yeah I mean the architecture for
these These are pretty simple you just
train one unconditional model this is
just like a standard diffusion model
like a unit that's unconditional or just
condition on class on text only and then
the rest are just super super resolution
models and then for this uh
architecturally is very simple you can
just uh for for an unconditional model
you just feed in epsilon uh or sorry
feed in the noise The Noise video or
noise image uh and then if you want to
condition on a low resolution thing all
you have to do is just you just you
upsample it using some sort of
upsampling method to to be the same size
as your
input concatenate it over like Channel
dimens mention and then you can just
feed it through the the model and know
just everything else is
identical um the one really nice thing
about these casc models is that
especially if you're on like a compute
budget where I only have X amount of GPS
available um you can then what you're
doing is you're just breaking up this
problem to a lot of independent smaller
pieces um so each of these models uh so
maybe if you want to train the whole
thing to generate 256 all at once maybe
the whole model will have to be like 3
billion parameters but maybe for uh for
this you can distribute it to be like
one billion model for each for each
resolution or maybe two two billion
models here or two billion parameters
here and like like 0.5b like 0.5b or
something um and then each of these
models by itself is more manageable to
train and you can also do more specific
hyper paramet tuning because especially
for diffusion models in literature it's
been it's been shown that like higher
resolution and lower resolution need
very different hyperparameters
um like stuff like that like for the
noise schedules how much noise you want
to add are usually pretty different for
for each resolution um so if you split
up the problem like this and makes it
easier to manage but it's a little bit
more annoying because you have to then
train all these different models and
your pipeline's a little bit more
complicated okay I'll try to speed up a
little bit
um let's let's skip this
um so here is so this is some examples
from their initial
results uh very I guess this is still
low like everything is still kind of low
resolution here the base was 16 x 16
which is pretty blurry and then they had
an upsample a super resolution model of
16 to 64x
64 yeah nothing nothing too
surprising
uh we can we can skip this too um so the
okay so I guess so then the scaled up
version of this on video so Peter talked
about imagine which was a pretty scaled
up version of cascaded diffusion models
I talked about and imagine video is just
a lot of Cascades you you can see so
this is the the Tex portion here
everything to the
left uh and then everything after that
is slowly generating the video to result
in basically 1280 x 768 24
FPS over I guess like 5 Seconds um um or
they have the base model which is
unconditional then they they do super
resolution over time then over over
space then over
space then time then time then space I
don't know how they chose when to do
what um I guess it seems reasonable it's
like somehow
inter and then one interesting thing is
you can see the model sizes start
decreasing as you go to higher and
higher resolution just because uh super
high resolution is just like a lot of
flops it's like a lot of computation
power you need so it becomes more
expensive and intuitively you also
probably don't need that much compute to
model the super resolution just because
like there's already so much information
from like 320 by 192 to 12 1280 x 768 um
there's only like a little bit of extra
information that you you might need to
introduce and the way their their their
model worked is it's kind of similar to
like stable video diffusion where you
have like but but this is all trained
from scratch so there's no
initialization from like a text to image
this is everything is trained from
scratch uh where you have uh things per
frame so you have like spatial
operations per frame and then you have
like temporal operations here and then
it's like spatial then temporal then
spatial then
temporal yeah so some key aspects here
is kind of as I mentioned the cascaded
structure allows better scalability
potentially or if you're on like a more
Li the compute
budget there was some augmentation they
added for super resolution models that
that was the aspect I kind of skipped
for the uh the Cascada models where you
can add some noise as you train the
super resolution models um very
important here this is probably one of
the more important things is video image
joint training um usually because image
text to image data is significantly more
diverse than text to video data and and
there's a lot more of it too um so then
if you want to capture certain things to
like different styles like like like
generating a video of X in in like a
painting style or like make it a sketch
or or something there might not be
actual text video data for that but if
you jointly train on both video and
images it it will generally transfer
some of that capabilities between the
two the the two like modalities because
they're very
close and also like a a decent high
quality data say you can train on which
is pretty important roughly 14 million
text video images and then 500 million
text
image
okay you can also imagine it running I I
guess it'll be like this for most of the
videos uh and and it's it should be
filling
up okay I guess I'll have figure out
what to do for the the video generation
lecture is that would
be
yeah um and then this is so I guess the
so those were all units still that I
talked about convolutional based models
and I guess the the latest thing is more
Transformers with all the latest
papers basically I mean architecturally
it's fairly simple so it's still the
same input and output as like a unit um
but in this case it's just like a vision
Transformer where you take your input
and you you patf it uh into tokens so
it's like a stried like 2 x two
convolution or 4x4 convolution and then
uh you flatten everything you feed it
through a Transformer and then it it
outputs
um it it it outputs like the It PRS the
noise and in this case it was based on
like the the paper from openi so they
also predict the the variance as well
and the main thing here is how they
introduced how you do the conditioning
of the time step edting um this is it's
very similar to how you I described the
like the modulated um aspect in the
units for time steps where you're um so
this is T embedding outputs the scale
and bias and also kind of like a gating
here between each layer that you can
apply and and that's like pretty much
the core
architecture this aspect is important I
think they bladed it but I think the
core thing here is just the transform
architecture and in general is more
scalable as as we'll
see so this was one paper that came out
I think December um called Walt from
Google that use
Transformers um this first part is just
a 3D CNN VA so very similar to let's say
the Vees for stable diffusion but just
for videos you just make it instead of
instead of 2D conss you make the conss
3D you make a down sample over space and
time uh to get something
like like uh like 32 by 32 by like 4 by
4 so like H by
W by C or
something
um with the exception that the first
frame is encoded separately so it's like
first frame is an image and then you
have the rest of like your your video
encoding so this is the only because
they can jointly trans image videos
still is still important and then after
that it's basically just like a
Transformer with slight with like maybe
a slightly fancier architecture of like
Factor wise
attention um they have zero
SNR which I talked about earlier um
instead of the added Len block that I
mentioned before it's like something
slightly different and they had
something called L and self conditioning
which I won't really go into but if
you're interested in There's the link to
the paper uh which you look at later um
and then their model was 3 billion
parameters so this is also much smaller
than imagine video imagine video in
total was maybe like 12 billion or 10
billion um but this was also this is
also a single model a single Transformer
model and this is a
things that have the potential to move
yeah but in general I think overall like
better motion than some of the other in
Imagine video for example not not not as
much uh weird things yes I'm just
curious so like it's interesting to me
you showing stuff where it's like they
do the spatial attention first and then
they do the temporal attention is that
better than doing Spa temporal attention
where it's all like all there like you
can uh I think you can like for uh for
this one I think it's just for
efficiency you can do like a factorized
detention it it's just like for
computational like benefits but you you
can just attend over everything do you
know there's if one is better than the
other I I would probably bet I mean in
the limit I would bet on just full
attention probably but if you if you're
yeah
yeah uh and a SORA which P talked about
there not really any details there's not
that much to mention
but it's also a diffusion Transformer
supposedly
um one interesting was they I guess one
of the other benefits of being a
Transformer and how you can tokenize
things is that it's very and then the
consequence is that after you tokenize
everything you flatten into one long
sequence so when you flatten everything
it becomes kind of agnostic to what the
original shape of what the shape of the
original input is you can always feed in
some information of the original shape
but then you can then flexibly do things
on different like different resolutions
I think they probably train things at
different resolutions maybe at different
time scales maybe like higher resolution
images with lower resolution images and
it's like so much easier if everything
is just like flattened out into a single
like 1D sequence versus trying to manage
to do this with like a unit and how to
make it support different resolutions
all at the same time and and I imagine
the training pipeline for that would be
horrendous
yeah and it could also been training
with some sort of random masking because
they do have different capabilities like
video prediction
infilling uh like extrapolation of some
sort but who
knows and today they had stable
diffusion 3 came out it's probably one
of the largest open source text or even
just text image models I know of of 8
billion parameters um this one was also
a diffusion Transformer so I don't know
why the last like two weeks have just
been Transformers for diffusion um they
mentioned using flow matching which we
don't cover in this class but I think
has been like a gen like a general
Paradigm that's been gaining more
traction lately so it could be
interesting to check the paper
out um okay cool yeah well we'll get
started in a sec here it's it's been a
it's it's a very packed lecture because
it's been a it's been a very fast moving
field so we're just going to finish up
with a few few more topics relating to
kind of diffusion models in practice so
we're going to talk a little bit about
how to sample from diffusion models uh
and then we'll talk a little bit about
how diffusion models can be used as
general representation learning um and
in fields other than images which they
also work up
to um so Progressive distillation Again
by uh by these two guys over here is is
kind of tackling this issue where
diffusion models are are quite they're
hard to sample from because they take a
lot of steps so even though diffusion
models do pretty good on on mode
matching and on um on image quality uh
because of this this assumption that you
have to progressively denot no the
diffusion model uh they take a long time
to sample for so basically the question
that they ask here in this paper is um
how can we how can we solve
that so if we look at the original ddpm
paper and and even this um followup the
diffusion model beat Gans paper they use
a thousand time steps of diffusion which
you you can see takes a long time
whereas if you're using something like a
vae or or again you you just have one
step so one thing we really want to do
is figure out how can we get this number
down
uh and having this large end is pretty
good for training uh basically and then
we'll go over this in one of the the
slides in the future um but basically as
Peter said early on the the reverse
process of the of the gaussian noising
process is only a gaussian with the
small enough step so we really do need a
small step to correctly train the
backwards process um but if we want to
actually evaluate this it might be nice
if we can skip steps if we can uh if we
cannot take these infantes small steps
but just take larger and larger ones so
the Insight here with uh Progressive
distillation is well let's take a
pre-train model that has end steps and
let's just try to cut cut it down by two
so if we can get a good procedure that
cuts down the number of steps by two
well then we can actually repeat this as
many times as we want uh and then see
how how close we can get without losing
construction
accuracy so as a quick overview in the
standard diffusion modeling process we
would sample an image we would sample a
Time step and an Epsilon a noise
parameter we would add Epsilon to X and
then we would update the model to
predict the original X or in some cases
You can predict Epsilon or or V the
combination of X Epsilon and
X um but but kind of if if you think
about predicting the original X it's
quite a tough distribution and actually
if your if your noise here is the fully
noise diffusion model uh predicting the
original X is actually this this very
hard problem that that's the the full
generation problem and and you can kind
of think that this problem is not
actually able to be modeled as a gaan
like the probability distribution of the
original data starting from nothing is
definitely more than aan it's a very
complicated
distribution and so uh it is aan if you
only predict back one step because
that's easier but the further you go the
the farther away your your true
distribution actually is from
aan uh but the main idea in in
Progressive distillation is if you have
this teacher model then what we can do
is we can actually predict uh what just
EX what the teacher
predicting so here let's say we started
with this image X um and we we noised it
to get let's call it x x hat here uh in
a standard diffusion model we would
predict back to X so let's call this x0
we would try to predict this but this is
a very hard problem what we can do
instead is we can kind of get this
x here of um T minus 2 something like
this so we can we can get we actually
know what this kind of slightly unno
version is from the the
teacher uh and we just want to predict
we just want to train our our student to
to match this and here we actually just
run it twice so so the basic idea is
take your teacher model and run the D
noising process twice and then train
your student model to copy the the twice
diffusion process in one step instead so
it's actually turns out to be a very
simple method basically train the
teacher and then train the student to
predict it a times two this may be a bad
question but I'm wondering why if like
the original model is like a thousand
why not just train a new model using
like 500 steps because when you train
you're just like sampling a t and then
you're immediately jumping to that like
image at that particular step yeah so so
the the answer is is basically has to do
with this down here where the more the
more diffusion steps you try to to uh
learn the mapping from the reverse
process from the harder the problem is
uh and in the diffusion backwards
process we kind of assume that the the
true backwards process distribution is a
gausian uh but it's not actually
true um whereas the the prediction
that's not all the way back to the the
unno image uh but only some steps is
kind of closer to the caution so that's
the reason why it's kind of better to
run the teacher model first to actually
learn all those marginal distributions
uh and then just copy those instead of
trying to go all the way back you could
inact you could try to train a diffusion
model with just less steps um it's not
as good as as training the full model
first and then doing the
distillation uh so this is kind of a
diagram of of what they're doing here
basically we start from this let's say
this is the teacher model with the
diffusion step of of four time steps
what we would do is we would uh
basically distill it down into a second
diffusion model that that tries to model
two steps in a single step and then all
the way down to one over
here
uh and here's some examples of of how it
works so here we we train first the the
the full teacher model here with 256
sampling steps uh you can kind of see
quality is quite good and in fact they
can take it all the way down to to four
so so from 256 to four steps uh and the
quality is is roughly the same uh you
can see that I mean there is some some
blurring but um like I mean this image
is very close to the image over here uh
going from four to one is where it gets
to be a problem and and you can see like
the the images over here they're
although they kind of have the same
semantic structure uh they're missing a
lot of details like this this dog over
here is is missing the ear and if you
look too closely you'll realize it's
it's kind of Faking a lot of the
details so one kind of lesson to learn
is you can actually get pretty far
distilling down image based diffusion
models down to around the realm of 16 or
18 steps without many tricks you can
just do this procedure here but getting
down from kind of 8 to to two or one is
where we'll really need some some more
insights so that's what's coming
up um yeah
so here's kind of one one problem with
with the methodology we we talked about
before so in the in the Progressive
distillation paper we try to to distill
many steps of diffusion process into one
step the problem is that this model of
of that predicts all of these steps here
is still assumed to be a gausian gausian
model so it's assumed that the True
Image is this gausian distrib centered
around some mean and we kind of know
that in practice that's that's not the
case we we need a more expressive
distribution um it's a gan here only
only for small step sizes uh and the
true distribution here
definitely is it's much more complicated
and the way that a normal diffusion
model would constructed as as the
sequence of of den noising steps so if
we want to do all of it at once oh we're
going to need basically a more a more
powerful generative
model yeah here here's kind of an
example of the problem of that that you
encounter as you try to make your your
diffusion step closer to or basically
you try to use less diffusion steps
so here's like the here's this
distribution that we start out here so
assume my data kind of looks something
like this and I as I add more and more
gausa noise to it uh progressively it
looks more and more this
way uh and then the question is let's
try to predict the noise um or let's try
to predict this this kind of noise that
was
added and you can see that if you if
you're at the very end so if if you're
diffusing back only one step the true
answer and in this case we can we know
the true answer because it's just one
dimensional looks very much like a gan
right this is this is a nice Gan we're
we're good but as we try to jump back
more more and more steps uh the actual
true distribution of the data looks more
and more shaped and and over here I mean
basically it looks basically the same as
as our X Z over there so this is kind of
the issue of this like this gausian
assumption just does not hold if your
step size is too
small so what they propose in this paper
is well we have powerful generative
models we covered Gans in lecture last
week we can use one here so we're going
to swap out this um this gussion assion
on the reverse distribution with a again
uh and basically what we want to do is
we want this the discriminator of the G
to predict or to distinguish between uh
this kind of one step D noise process
given the noise image um versus the true
the true d noised one so Q is what what
the data has we want to we want to mimic
that with the with the
Gan uh and and kind of there there's a
trick here which is the question is how
do you get Q right if if we knew Q we we
could just run q and that would solve
our that would solve our problem but in
practice we we don't actually know q q
is actually the marginal under the data
but we can sample from it and so the
trick is that this Q distribution right
here actually expands out to just be uh
this little marginal right
here so what this equation here is
saying is sample an image first just a
regular image um
and
then noise it one
step um but then noise and then noise it
one more step so it's basically saying
like Okay let's say I have this original
image I'm going to noise it n steps and
I'm going to noise it n plus one steps
after that so now I have this pair the
the image that's slightly noise and
slightly more noise uh and that is what
we consider the the true data so that's
the true kind of distribution of of
noise data to slightly unno data so this
is the the objective that we want our
discriminator to Mark as as correct and
then the object the examples that are
marked as incorrect will be the ones
generated by our model so we're going to
train the the generator by backing
through the discriminator as we usually
do in
gas so again main idea here is swap out
that that gaussian prediction of one
step with with a gan that can produce
something that's more
expressive um yeah here's kind of a
diagram of of what the method is doing
it's basically saying first let's take
the sample image and we're going to
noise it and then we're going to noise
it a little more and now I want my Gan
to B basically predict this version of
the image that was slightly less noised
um uh which is captured by the
discriminator so the idea is that this
process here because it's modeled by the
Gan can be a lot more expressive of a
distribution than the the onestep Goan
assumption we had
earlier so here's some examples of of
how it works this is with again just
four diffusion steps and we can get
quite nice high resolution results so
here's some image of of celebrity faces
and of the the church data set
here sorry but was it also trained with
just for
steps um yeah it's trained at four
steps so in this paper they yeah yeah
they train this completely from scratch
this this diffusion can so that you swap
out all of the networks for this uh and
and we're going to see in in a followup
paper you can use the same setup for for
distillation and that actually uh I
think works
better uh yeah so here here's mobile
diffusion so this is something that came
out I think less than a year ago but
introduces a bunch of tricks for
speeding up G couple weeks ago sorry not
a couple weeks ago earlier this year
earlier last year earli last year it's
very time moves very fast uh but yeah so
so I think this paper is nice because it
gives us a bunch of tricks for actually
how to train uh diffusion models faster
so if we can just get inference time
faster then sampling becomes lot easier
and for these guys they want it to run
on your on your phone they want it to
run locally so it's important that the
parameter count goes
down um so basically there's a few
architectural tricks that that uh reduce
in that basically can reduce the
parameter
count uh one of the main ideas is this
um just put your Transformers in the
middle of the unit so we talk Al a
little about this before but the main
idea is if you look at a unit you start
out with images at a very high spatial
resolution so your your input data is
maybe let's call it 128 by 128 um and
each step it's it's collapsing in in
height and width so maybe at the end
here you're at a latent space of let's
say 16 x
16 uh intuitively the the features in
the inner layers are more are more um
compressed they're more kind of
expressive whereas the features on the
outside are more focused on the high
frequency details so it's kind of useful
to put your Transformers More in the
Middle where they can perform the more
advanced
computation uh and so if you had to
assign your parameter count instead of
doing it uniformly like we were doing in
the past it's better to put the more in
the middle and that gives us a pretty
large efficiency gain uh without loss of
performance uh the other thing that they
do here is they decouple the the self
attention and and the cross
attention what this essentially means is
in a in a text conditioned diffusion
model uh each layer attends to itself
and also the text conditioning so it
attends to basically the global
structure and also the the local
structure of the image at the moment so
cross attention of the text is pretty
important you need that at every layer
uh but self attention you actually don't
need at every layer and and in fact
because of the same reason we're we're
in the early and later layers of the
unit your your spatial resolution is
just so big self attention takes up a
lot of time when you actually you don't
need it so again cut it out on the on
the outsides and just put it on the
inside uh and then there's a few kind of
even more uh architectural details here
we don't have to go too much into them
but there there are some things we can
get away with which is when you're
Computing your attention something you
can do is uh instead of computing your
key and your value as two separate heads
you can actually just use one head and
it turns out for in ter for diffusion
that's fine uh we can get away with with
merging those and reducing parameter
count
uh and one thing we can do here is we
can get rid of the soft Max so in
attention when you compute the attention
waiting you have to you take the dot
product between all your key vectors uh
and then you normalize it by the the sum
of of all the other dot product uh and
you can see that that's kind of annoying
because you have to wait for all the
sums to come by to to be done before you
can actually compute waiting so what
they found in this paper is uh we can
train with softmax which is fine we have
a lot of time to train uh but during
evaluation we want to use something
cheaper and they chose ra here and it
turns out what you can do is you can
just fine-tune a model that has softmax
activations to instead use Rao
activations and that fine-tuning process
is very cheap and then it speeds up
to yeah the rest of the improvements
here are kind of things like reducing
widths in the right places U reducing
residual blocks uh and then using this
separable convolutions idea that
basically let you compute the the
convolution
faster uh and we can see here that
here's the original stable diffusion
which has quite a large uh model size
because the parameter count meanwhile
mobile diffusion is able to get it down
to something a lot more reasonable and
you can see uh even in pra like even uh
when you evaluate it the time it takes
to for each evaluation goes
down so that's kind of two two Avenues
to speeding up the diffusion model one
is distilling your your many step model
down into small steps and then two is
just make each step run a little faster
uh and then that adds
up uh here's something we're not going
to go into too much detail hourglass
diffusion Transformer uh but basically
it's a similar idea to this mobile
diffusion where uh what they do is they
they have this unit where they put more
more Transformer parameters near the
middle
here uh yeah here's a fun paper because
it just came it just came out uh two two
days ago I think what day is it but it
just came out earlier this week uh
yesterday oh yesterday oh my go yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so let's go let's go
see what they
do uh yeah so so the key idea here is we
talked about that Gan idea and we
noticed how Gans solve the problem where
as you as you reduce the number of
diffusion steps your gausian assumption
goes away so these guys are saying well
okay let's do distillation but let's
just use a gan instead so instead let's
replace this gussion thing with a gan um
and this solves the problem of the
uh sorry this thing okay
yeah okay yeah the go so the the Gan is
not enough we need to use something more
powerful in this case let's use the
Gan uh and so how do they do this well
they they do essentially this the
similar thing as as we were talking
about in the in the other diffusion Gan
paper
where this time you use the teacher
Network as the source of Truth so before
we were using uh kind of noise samples
from the data here we're just using
directly the outputs of the teacher
Network so
your um your discriminator is going to
condition on basically uh this uh X
noised image and then x with uh with
some some de noising applied to it so
that's what this exis is the original
image noised um and then the the kind of
further D noise version of it uh and
here we also make sure like we we tell
it the time steps with the amount of
noise and also the the text conditioning
here um and then what one of the nice
tricks you can do is if you ever do
these kind of distillation things you
can reuse a lot of the weights so you
don't have to train this discriminator
from scratch we actually initialize it
um from the teacher Network so the
teacher Network already has this uh
encoding portion of the unit so if you
remember the unit looks something like
this uh we can take this part and reuse
those weights and we trained the new a
new network over here for use in the
discriminator uh here's a fun thing so
if your student model has less capacity
than your teacher model which is almost
always true you actually get this kind
of mismatch in how well you can model uh
the diffusion Direction and and what's
they they call this the the Janus
artifacts here after this like this
multi-headed God essentially because one
of the ways that this manifest is you
end up with pictures like this where uh
the diffusion process essentially tries
to to
model exactly what the teacher is doing
but it doesn't have enough capacity to
smooth out all the errors uh so you get
things like this where the the image is
very much IND distribution of of
possible uh D noise versions of the
image but as a whole it's not it's not
correct so you have you have things
where uh the head gets split into
two so the way that they solve it in
this paper is
relaxing this mode coverage assumption
uh is a trick to to reduce the
complexity of the
problem uh and they do that by
fine-tuning on an unconditional teacher
so the the first problem that they try
to to solve is is to optimize this value
which is given a noised image uh give me
the image that's slightly denoised but
this problem is very hard and it leads
to these artifacts so what they do is
they first train this and then they do
this where this model is not condition
on XT it's only saying just
make uh just give me D images that are
probable in general like among the
entire data uh and this actually can
solve the these images because these
images here are not actually probable
under the data um so this this kind of
unconditional fine tuning after the
first step will solve that
problem uh here's the details of exactly
what they're doing so the the first
thing they do is they they start with
this um 128 step diffusion model and
they actually do the first few steps of
distillation with the regular MSE loss
so the the first progressive
distillation paper uh can get us down to
to 32 without much loss and it's easier
to
train but then if we want to compress it
even more well now we need to escape
this gussian assumption and need to use
a more expressive model that's when
we're going to use the the Gan
distillation so they have these
different stages and in each stage what
they do is they first do the the the
conditional training U conditioned on
the original noised image uh then they
fine-tune to the unconditional to get
the that Network and then they use that
Network as the teacher for the next
Network under
it um yeah and then one thing they
realize is that you can also use um
Laura so Laura is this basically trick
to do to do fine tuning with lower
parameter count so it's basically this
way to make a a low rank approximation
of the the full
parameters basically it's it's faster
but it'll it'll give you less expressive
results but they show in this paper that
if you're just doing distillation um
it's totally fine to actually find tune
these Lowa parameters only uh and you
get performance that's about about equal
to to what they have without
it uh yeah here here's some results here
so here's an image of a yeah tanned
women dressing Sports were in sunglasses
climbing a peak with the group uh I
think none of them actually got the
group part but we're going to see how
how much the the performance degrades so
this is the original here this is um or
this is sdxl the thing that they're
going to compare to uh and then here
we're fine-tuning it from 32 steps down
to 8 4 and two uh and we can see that
yeah the the kind of generation quality
here at two is still pretty expressive
so you still get a lot of the the
detailing
and uh and and here LCM is just a
different method that they're comparing
to
yeah
so yeah so that that's basically if if
you want to speed up diffusion models I
think a lot of people are thinking about
this recently uh there's definitely a
lot of unanswered questions
there um do they evaluate whether they
lose diversity in the
process uh I'm not sure off the top of
my head I think we would they probably
mention it somewhere in this paper
um I I couldn't give a concrete answer
now I imagine they
would one nice thing about these these
distillation processes is that they try
to make sure that the noise to image
mapping remains constant so so you can
see here like even through the the
distillation process you're still
getting the same type of image from the
same initial noise so because we're
doing distillation that mapping from
from noise to image is triy is trying to
um be constant
yeah
I yeah we're trying to replace like
let's say many steps of denoising
process with a single step of the gam
output so I
remember
model provides better
diversity
that you get yeah it's a good question I
don't think I could give a good answer
off the top of my head although
basically one rationale for why we want
to use distillation instead of training
the the diffusion G directly as the the
second paper did is that when you do
distillation you're explicitly trying to
keep this mapping between noise and
generated image which inherently keeps
the diversity that that the original
diffusion model had so you can say as
long as we got all that diversity during
their initial training we try to to keep
it during distillation whereas if you
just train the the scan at first you
might not get
it uh yeah so one other thing we could
do with with diffusion
models um is use them not for Generation
but actually just for for understanding
the world
world one of the first things we we we
covered in this unsupervised class
actually was that a reason that we want
to use UNS supervis methods is that they
they give us good representation
learning so they give us good
information about the world without
necessarily having to use labeled data
so the question now is can we use
diffusion models for
this and um here here we're trying to
do
sorry let me just yeah so so so here
here we're trying to to learn
correspondences so we're trying to learn
which parts of images correspond to to
other parts of
images so maybe actually these slid
should be reordered um we we want to do
something like this where given the
let's say here they've highlighted the
beak of of the goose here they want to
highlight that same component in other
images so basically this is a way of
learning some sort of semantic
information about each image
and the question is well we train this
diffusion model purely to generate
images can we actually reuse it to get
out something like
this uh and the main Insight here is the
diffusion models are are trained using
noisy images as input so the diffusion
model always takes in some noise version
and outputs a cleaner version so if we
want to extract features out what we
actually need to do is add noise to
whatever image we care about so we need
to add some noise to get the image in
distribution of the diffusion model um
and then we can run that image through
through the model itself uh and here
what they do is they just take out
features uh at a certain layer so they
they take some layer in the middle of
the unit and use those features to
compute cosine distance uh and the main
idea is well we can just take this coine
distance and use that as a metric for
how much our semantics match each
other um and this interesting thing is
yeah as as your amount of noising
changes uh the the trade-off you get
between semantics and details will will
also change so if you add a high amount
of noise you might get features that
correspond to high level parts of the
image like where an object is but if you
add a small amount of noise you you will
get semantics that correspond to finer
things such as texture or
color um so this is what they can do
using purely a pre-train diffusion model
they can basically find all these
correspondences and they can give a a
labeled part of this image here can find
that same part on on all these test
images um here's another fun thing you
can do once you have these kind of
semantic correspondences that they give
you the positional info of of where
features are so what they do in this
paper is they they took the face and
they just added some uh they added
googly eyes in a stuck out tongue and
they say let's try to add this in the
same place uh on other images so this is
essentially like a a zero shot way of of
doing image editing where if they add it
in the original image then they can add
that same feature and in the semantic
location uh of the other images uh and
this just occurs basically without
having to find you the
model um yeah here's another paper
trying to figure out how we can extract
features from uh from a diffusion model
here we want to do classification so
here we want to use the diffusion model
see like how well does this correspond
to let's say a given image netclass or
even a text
label so we want to classify images um
and kind of a another way to do
classification is if we can just learn
this distance so if you can learn a
distance between image and text that's
essentially something we can use as as
class label
info uh and the main Insight here is our
diffusion model is is kind of giving us
this model here so where C is your your
class or your text conditioning we have
this idea we have this distribution over
images that match that conditioning
so if we plug that into Bas R we can get
the the opposite thing so we can get the
the class condition on image um as long
as we have these marginals
here and if we if we uh just assume
classes are all uniform we can actually
cross out these numbers uh which makes
this a lot more tractable to
do so the main idea that that these guys
use is given this input image here what
they do first is they noise it so if you
want to use it as input at the divion
model you need to add some noise
first um and then what they do is they
diffuse the model where the class the
conditioning is equal to uh the given
class so so let's say I'm working with
imag net I might try out like bird car
or truck uh and I would get a different
Epsilon for each for each
answer uh and then what we want to do
here is we just want to compute the
distance between this predicted Epsilon
and the true Epsilon that we use to
noise the image in the first
place uh and then this the distance
between epsilons here is basically the
distance uh between the image and the
text and so now we can compute which
class is the most likely just by taking
basically which of these distances is
the smallest
one so it's a nice way to basically
invert the diffusion model and say okay
if we have a mapping one way from text
to images uh we can use it in reverse to
go from images to text and just find
this
distance
um yeah here here's one one more work on
doing kind of representation learning
where here the question is we want to do
pixel level segmentation so we we want
to care about finding semantic maps in
an image of which parts correspond to to
certain
objects uh so the first thing we can
start with is there's kind of a low
resolution hacky way to do it which they
actually start with in this paper which
is let's extract some feature Maps so
let's assume we we pass the image into
the diffusion model we have some feat
features uh we can just use K means so K
means is this nice cheap way to do
clustering uh if you use K means on
feature space you would get some
semantic correlations between those
features um and and one one kind of nice
trick that they use in this paper is uh
if you're using a text condition
diffusion model you want to use your
your query vectors as features where
query is is the the query used for cross
attention with the text so in some way
this query Vector is meaning like what
do I care about in my text conditioning
uh which corresponds nicely to what the
segmentation should
be so now that we have these kind of low
resolution feature Maps we just want to
upscale it so we want to figure out the
correspondence from features to the
actual pixels in the
image uh and the way to do that is we
can use this what they call this
modulation strategy which is that we add
this this constant number to those
features uh and see what how that
affects the generated image so the idea
here is if we had these kind of
intermediate features which which I'll
call Z and we have the the rest of the
diffusion model and they so the output
is X what we want to do is basically
measure how how Z Plus Delta maps to a
new
x uh and we want to do Z minus Delta and
map that to a different X and the
difference between these two is
essentially how much that that feature
affects the corresponding
pixel here's a visualization of of how
it ends up looking so given uh this kind
of image here the low
resolution feature maps that they use K
means defined end up being things like
this so you you have this very uh
pixelated space because it's in low res
but you have some some kind of starting
segmentation map for which things
correspond to different items uh and
then using the modulation process we can
figure out uh which pixels actually
correspond and with what weighting to
those features here and so if you
compose these together this ends up
being our segmentation map that we
get these are some some final
segmentation Maps you get if you run
this so again we we get a lot of nice um
semantic areas here like the the ocean
for example is segmented differently as
the the shallow water and the beach uh
and you have all the people given us
different
areas so I think these methods are kind
of interesting because they they show us
that we're just trading what we thought
was originally an image generation model
but actually by by solving this reverse
diffusion process it has to learn a lot
of these features it has to learn a lot
of the the cement and content um and if
we use the right ways to to get it out
it actually contains it you can get all
these these powerful
representations out of the
model yeah so kind of as a way to wrap
up the lecture I can talk a little bit
about how diffusion models have been
used in fields that are that are not
images and this I hope will open up your
your minds to showing that the
generative modeling we do here uh
although they've seen a lot of success
in images they can be used very easily
in in other applications as
well uh unit mat this is actually worked
by by Sherry from from
Berkeley um what's what is this um yeah
this they try to use diffusion here for
for material generation so the idea here
is we want to generate these these
structures that that are likely to to
still stick together in the real world
so in this case we have we can Define
our our materials as these these atoms
with various XYZ positions and the idea
is we want to train a generative model
over these
materials uh and what they do is they
just treat basically the the parameters
of these cells as this big um Matrix and
they they can do diffusion over the the
coordinates of each each each
element uh and here there there's kind
of a nice trick where some elements
shouldn't exist so some elements don't
won't exist in the in the final material
here um it's over there you can't really
see it so they use this null location so
they basically just say like materials
like or atoms that exist here that we
don't want to actually put in the final
thing should be mapped to this this
area
um so so that that is one thing to keep
in mind of diffusion it's it's generally
it's a continuous process so you do want
your your underlying data to kind of
have this continuous uh representation
and if you have something that's more
discreet you're going to have to use
some tricks to to move it
over uh this is a paper that shows that
you can use diffusion models to do uh
Locomotion planning
so here here the diffusion process is
using the the XY positions of joints in
this simulated robot um and what we're
trying to do is predict how the robot
will behave as we move into the future
uh and then the nice thing about
diffusion models is we can predict not
only how it's going to appear one step
in the future but actually how it'll
appear across this entire trajectory so
this whole sequence basically becomes
this Matrix where you have your your
features here and then you have you have
time over here and this entire thing can
be passed uh into the diffusion model so
you can see here like a lot of the joint
positions start out in this noise state
which is corresponding to to that noised
image State we looked at earlier um and
as you do D noising they gradually fall
into place and you get trajectories that
are a lot more consistent than if you
had used a one-step trajectory
model diffusion policy is also this this
kind of nice application uh into
robotics where we've seen diffusion be
applied
um and there there's kind of this issue
when when doing naive uh robotic trading
where let's say we want to we want a
robot to clone a set of expert
demonstrations well usually these
demonstrations are actually pretty
multimodal there are many ways that a
human might solve a problem but if you
try to capture all these different modes
with a single gaussian
policy um you end up not being able to
fit it you end up in this problem where
uh you if I have a lot of probability
Mass here and here then I might model
the gu like this which is which is not
actually matching either of the modes uh
but if we Define our our distribution as
a as a diffusion model instead that can
Model A more complex distributions we
actually get distributions that that
correctly model the actions here so here
here's one kind of motivating example
where you have this blob here that can
move either of the two directions and
the diffusion model actually captures
both of these modes and is able to get
to to Route the the robot in the right
way whereas some previous methods might
either be messy or it might um get only
one of those
modes here is an example of how this is
looking like in practice so you
would here the robot we're trying to
control the end effector so we can
basically move this this thing around
and we want it to to push that t to
rotate it into the correct position and
so the actions here correspond to what
position um this end tip of the robot
should be uh and so basically we can do
is we can just diffuse over all these
actions so starting from noise actions
we're gradually going to move over to
the actions that are within the data
distribution and it turns out that this
diffusion policy work um is a pretty
reliable way to do this kind of behavior
cloning and uh over at this um see if
this labeled there yeah this the Toyota
Research Institute actually they're
using this to to model a whole bunch of
different kinds of behaviors so they
have some videos on the website that
we'll play if you want to look at them
but the main idea is this is is actually
a pretty scalable way to do some do some
robotic
training okay yeah I think that's that's
kind of wrapping up our our talk on
diffusion model so there there's a few
more um links here if you want to check
them out in the slides that that go over
in more depth um either the derivations
or some some more important some more
applications of
them um yeah and if you're interested
there's some kind of advanced topics
relating diffusions to to other aspects
as
well
thanks
k